before this video begins I have an
important announcement you want to hear
about this there's a new app called
nemesis where if you download it your
life will become a social media game as
soon as you register every single minute
of your life will be quantified Internet
occurrence and this is collected from
since you register not just how much you
use your phone or you spend in the app
so the more names you have the more
powerful and influence you get now just
imagine for a second if everyone
downloaded is that it's a pretty insane
concept I don't think I heard about any
idea anywhere like this excepting sci-fi
scenarios nemesis users could
potentially buy real things in the
future using their names like your next
Tesla or your next represent coms slash
PewDiePie merch collection there are
social roles within the app such as the
user and icon you get your names you own
them and then you save them and everyone
sees how many names you have you can be
a regular users or you can actually try
and grow your influence and reach the
unreachable icon status just imagine if
everyone was using this I think it's a
pretty insane idea and I'm really
curious to see how it's gonna work out
so sign up follow me there invite your
friends as well because then you get
more NIMS the idea is to turning human
life into a source of financial capital
I'm really really really curious about
this and through the cord PewDiePie so I
get referral names thank you very much
check it out and follow me there I'll be
using nemesis from now on let's get on
with the video
good evening I'm Mary ham and welcome to
ham news first of all Mary ham news have
reached the highest ratings it has ever
gotten oh boy all the comments have been
so supportive no one likes you Mary ham
I'm not a fan of marry him no I refuse
to watch with him area ham I hate him I
hate you marry him get papi Gloria back
papi Gloria is dead okay she did an
oopsie get it into your thick skulls
already she ain't coming back yes I may
have killed her but that doesn't prove
I'm innocent now let's get into the news
our first story comes from Sid who has
now responded to dead G his brother
calling him out in not just one video
but two videos and ksi has now finally
responded so you thought going on low
composed podcasts to talk about me was
the best way to branch out for my bro we
went on there to talk about something
else than fine but you did it it was all
pretty much about me the best way H to
branch out from me is to not talk about
me at all and then on top of that make
good quality content that your fans
would enjoy does he have a god complex
is it that's what I mean like his ego is
insane he's like year is distracted
cordetta he compared himself to Aries
brah maybe Devi has some points that are
fair maybe case I wasn't great brother
or whatever but I think case I did a
really good job explaining his side of
the situation you can talk to me
especially if you having dark thoughts
or just feeling low I'm always here for
you whether we're on good times or bad
terms whenever you message me I always
replied edge I want you to succeed in
everything you do but Deji man you have
to communicate with me how how else am I
going to know how you're feeling and I
got
say like hatreds video has mid-roll
zoning he comes with his video out of
nowhere with the video that has mid
rolls on it 42 minutes right after the
whole tattoo situation became a huge
viral thing and it's kind of hard to
side with someone that puts that
perspective on it especially when case I
made it a lot of good points I'm sorry
case I also said that in his video he's
gonna donate all the ad revenue to
suicide prevention charities and in
light of day G being in the dark place
but then I don't know where Logan Paul
decided to animate laugh and claim the
video haha fu [ __ ] if you don't see ads
it's because it's being claimed by Logan
Paul's Network Logan
what the Frick are you doing do you want
people to hate you what history's money
go into suicide prevention charities
Logan Paul haha now it's clear let Logan
Paul didn't know this and he said I
jumped the gun on that one I'll make
sure the automatic claim is removed case
I've still a PP this whole situations is
dumb it's dummy dumb dummy dumb dumb now
let's go into probably the biggest noise
I have ever heard Jesus and it's about
the steven crowder versus carlos masa
situation but this head here and the
other head here they here they are it
all started with Fox News reporter
Carlos masa who wrote in his Twitter so
I have pretty thick skin when it comes
to online harassment but something has
been really bothering me he pointed out
how whenever steven crowder debunks his
videos he also ridicules his sexual
orientation and ethnicity before we get
to the video with our favorite favorite
and lispy right it's ridiculous it's
bonkers you're being given a free pass
as a crappy writer because you're gay
that's Federline on his a little queer
graph there now the graph is queerness
violence Phil okay so the little queer
could eat his chips all nonchalantly
it's code for Ray mr. queer eating chess
on the box channel Thanks this is what
mr. gay Vox wants to do mister let's be
queer from Bach now Steven
for those who you don't know is a
right-wing youtuber and apparently
according to himself he's the biggest
conservative channel on YouTube wait is
that true
how many does ben shapiro have 1.7 bruh
massa also pointed out how he got doxxed
and he got a bunch of text messages
saying debates even Crowder
now blurred the numbers but I like how
Massa complains about being darks and
then he talks is all these people
regardless he also points out how
YouTube's policies against harassment
and bullying are not aligned with the
comments that Steven has said about him
that being said I'm not mad at at
Crowder well that's a lie are you sure
about that but he does raise a good
point I mean I haven't even seen this
content that is deliberately posted in
order to humiliate someone content that
makes hurtful and negative personal
comments videos about that person that's
so vague but it does apply doesn't it
yeah he does have a point Carlos also
pointed out how steven crowder sells a
shirt that says socialism is for FIGS
although it's one of those edgy jokes
that it can be interpreting their way
and he sees it as socialism is for facts
now this shirt will be important later
okay so let's just remember this shirt
for now I have to say I think it is good
that Massa speaks out there is a problem
with people there is a big issue online
where people with audiences criticize
each other which they should be able to
do but then the audience joins in and
makes the whole place toxic with
harassment daxing etc of these
individuals this is obviously not OK and
if anyone ever does it for me then you
can eat the fat Lord okay I want nothing
to do with you obviously most people
don't want this Crowder has spoken out
against this as well but it is a larger
issue that none of the less deserves to
be brought up so I think it's good he
spoke out however the timing of all this
is pretty interesting obviously this was
posted one day before Pride Month the
clips that showed about steven crowder
making fun of
were not new ones these are older clips
which made it seem like this was a
deliberate attack to go after Steven as
much as possible but also in a way if I
was going after someone that was way
bigger than me yes technically he works
under box was such a billion-dollar
company but he didn't tweet this out
through vogue okay he tweeted out it on
his personal Twitter so I will if I was
Mozza I would probably want some sort of
support to back me up as well so in a
way I can understand that it just seems
like the whole tone is more coming
across as aggressive as opposed to just
wanting to out him on his behavior mas a
is not just going after Crowder he's
also going after YouTube directly saying
that YouTube has this sort of flag and
and banner in support of Pride Month but
in reality he thinks that YouTube does
not give it Frick about queer creators
u2 does not give a freak about
marginalized creators YouTube does not
give a freak about diversity or
inclusion you to one's clicks you to
ones clicks you to once click now this
is either willfully ignorant or just
ignorant okay YouTube doesn't want
clicks okay YouTube has plenty of clicks
YouTube has a goddamn monopoly of clips
they don't need more clicks I don't know
how you can come to this conclusion
anyone working in the industry knows
this YouTube wants to avoid at all cost
a scandal that will make them lose
advertisers which is obviously what is
trying to get stirred up here at least
that's what it seems like to me and so
we did Washington Post posted a
right-wing youtuber hurled racist
homophobic taunts at a gay reporter the
company did nothing vice news saying
Google says right-wing YouTube star can
continue his racist and homophobic abuse
these are some pretty hefty headlines
YouTube decides that homophobic
harassment does not violate its policies
YouTube may allow hate speech if it's
part of a larger argument
yikes they put likes in the title
that's a yikes for me now I don't think
I've said this but I don't agree with
Steven's comments against massa yes I'm
probably not the right person to
criticize what someone says and yes
worse things are said almost every day
on YouTube honestly you cannot pay me to
wear one of these shirts
YouTube's response to this has been very
interesting because it's come in three
waves four waves number one first
YouTube says actually we reviewed all
hit Stevens content and we came to the
conclusion opinions can be deeply
offensive but if they don't violate our
policies they'll remain on our site so
basically YouTube saying we look into it
they don't violate the policies and it
seemed like that was gonna be it but
then YouTube
oh my emotion darude out of nowhere and
said update on our continued review we
have suspended this channels
monetization basically the monetizing
Steven Carter's entire channel we came
to this decision because of a pattern of
egregious actions has harmed the broader
community and is against our YouTube
Partner Program policy this was not
enough for call us at least and he
criticized this decision by saying that
he is selling merch that says socialism
is for [ __ ] and YouTube is basically
enabling this and then YouTube responded
to say in order to reinstate
monetization he will need to remove the
links to his t-shirt and I think Steven
has done that already actually but then
you to made another update Jesus Christ
sorry for confusion this channel is to
monetize due to continuous blah blah
blah to be reinstated he will need to
address all issues with his channel all
issues will be addressed apparently to
top all of this crate like back and
forth response from YouTube first saying
all we're fine with this then saying you
know what it's all monetized to top all
of this off YouTube I don't know where
they decided that they're gonna announce
their new policies against hate speech
YouTube's on their official blog said
our ongoing work to tackle hate ah the
same day the same goddamn day they did
this this left a lot of people confuse
okay a lot of people seem to think that
these two think the events are coin site
is that a word
sure YouTube has been planning this for
a long time okay they don't just change
their policies on a whim although I
guess they have in the past actually
basically what this new policy is saying
is that they're gonna go strike harder
on hateful content saying that they're
gonna remove hate
the premise content from YouTube saying
that they're gonna prohibit videos
alleging that a group is superior in
order to justify discrimination and
they're gonna remove videos denying
well-documented violent events and I
gotta say I'm all for this this is a
good update I don't really have a
problem with this previously YouTube has
dealt with this type of content and at
putting it in a locked state where
basically you can't engage with the
video no comment no likes no nothing
it's still technically on the site but
not really but now they're striking
harder on it and saying okay we're just
gonna remove it and great sure remove
hateful content I don't care but this
led a lot of people thinking okay this
is because of Carlos thing and now
because of him all these channels are
getting to monetize now because of this
it seemed like journalists that we're
posting videos in the context of
criticizing this type of content got
striked as well
even this History Channel got
demonetised completely and banned for
hate speech because apparently had some
Nazi propaganda speeches in it I'm
devastated to have this claim leveled
against me and frustrated that 15 years
of material for history teacher
community had ended so abruptly Jesus
Christ an update to this they did
reinstate his channel but why the hell
does this always happen why do all these
channels get them on so old frequently
this channel unjustly get demonetized
when it's someone's livelihood someone's
I worked on something for 15 years
YouTube has human people initiating the
final strike do a better job please
delete hateful comment by old means but
then at least make sure you know what
hateful comment content is now whatever
your opinion about masa or Steven I
think what really matters here is the
effect okay there's definitely even
tighter restrictions here on YouTube
many people pointed out how obviously
since Steven is a right-wing Channel and
Carlos is a left-wing Channel people
started pointing out the hypocrisy in
the enforcement of the policies because
a lot of people from the right saying
well people on the Left have actually
said way worse why don't they get it get
demonetized but because of this whole
event we have it now spelled out more
clearly that YouTube even themselves
said even if a creators content doesn't
violate our Community Guidelines we will
take a look at the broader context and
impact and if their behavior is
egregious and harms the broader
community we may take action so if you
make it it's not about who's right and
wrong it's about who makes the most
amount of noise and that's what Carlos
managed to do again I don't agree with
Stevens comment about it but if YouTube
it's so bizarre to me how it's not about
the what policies it is because the
policies against harassment and bullying
would take down way more content than
just this it happens all the time when
you do fine alone as someone who's been
attacked by the mainstream media steven
is most likely just going to benefit
from all of this happening ironically it
is the Streisand effect and that's just
how it works now today in awesome news
Ella had the baby hey Ethan Aniela
delivered the baby this is why do I say
like both of them did it congratulations
to Ethan and Neil app that's amazing I'm
so happy for you guys
that's just good news I just wanted to
have some good news in here great news
fantastic news
I'm at downtown LA next news in from
Instagram influencer with 2.6 followers
million followers struggles to sell 36
t-shirts ah this was going viral on
Twitter with hundred and fifteen
thousand likes the influencer bubble is
bursting this young lady has well over 2
million followers and couldn't sell 36
shirts Jesus Christ it breaks my heart
to have to write this post I poured my
heart into this drop for my photo shoot
I flew out a photographer and makeup
artist okay well it doesn't look that
good there's a lot of things that go
into selling mark I haven't released
merch
many years ago where I had more than 2
million followers that's sold like 50 or
something like that because it was
either boring design
or people just didn't care enough about
it where I marketed it poorly now I sell
merch very ethically because people
actually care about what merry hem has
to say and they actually listen to him
go to represent dot-com sighs PewDiePie
right now and buy the latest merge to
support the channel goddamnit it's not
that freaking hard on the idea that the
influencer bubble is bursting it just
sounds so goddamn stupid I will say
though there seems to be so many
Instagram in influencers don't pay them
ok pay me all right dear brains if you
are listening to this video
taemi we have reached the end of the
video I have an important announcement
to make
I am poppy Gloria all alone what what
you never played tuber simulator you
know it's fun right I'm not supposed to
give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]